-You were telling me backstage,
and I don't know if you wanted
to talk about this,
but I wanted to bring it up
that you were thinking about
getting into something new.
And it just intrigued me because
it didn't seem like something
that Kiefer Sutherland
would get into.
-I wanted to --
Well, I want
to get into farming.
I started -- There we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
There's three farmers
out there.
-Three farmers out there,
but, you --
-And I'm not a farmer.
I'm learning.
I'm reading books about it.
I started cooking.
Well, I have children
and I have grandchildren,
so I took cooking lessons,
because I didn't want
to kill them
accidentally with an undercooked
turkey or something.
-Yeah. Yeah, of course.
Yeah, of course.
-And I fell in love with it.
And during the pandemic,
I cooked a lot.
And I got into the produce
that that I was using for food.
And I thought, "Well, I've seen
a couple of documentaries,
and maybe I'd like
to actually try growing
some of this food," and --
-I can't see you in, like,
overalls
and really going for it
and, like, getting a tractor.
I mean --
-Very, very few people can.
-Yeah. Do you have
a green thumb?
-Mainly my family. No.
And that's the hard part,
that's why I have all the books.
No. Whatever the opposite color
of green is the thumb
that I have.
-Yeah.
-When my daughter was about
4 years old,
we went to the hardware store
and got a bunch
of different seeds and looking
for the easiest thing to grow.
And those are daisies,
because they're weeds.
And we planted them
all over the house,
and I thought,
"How nice this is gonna be
when she goes to school
next year,
we'll be picking
these fresh daisies."
Seven years later, nothing.
Nothing grew.
-You really have no experience
and no green thumb at all?
-No, the worst,
the worst.
-But I think that you
like a challenge, so I think --
-I do.
And I also want to --
I want livestock, which is even
more challenging --
-This is where you get
out of control.
What do you mean, now?
Like, what kind of livestock
are you talking here?
-Well, I want I want
two donkeys.
I want some chickens.
I want a couple of goats.
I'm going the whole 100 yards.
-I love that you're doing that.
What are you gonna do
with the donkey?
-I'm gonna walk him.
-Walk a donkey?
-Well, anybody can walk a dog,
right?
I mean, if you could walk
a donkey, would that not be fun?
-No -- Well, if I could walk
a donkey?
-Yeah.
-Yeah. I mean, yeah,
I can't wait to ask you.
I can't wait to see
what happens in six months.
-Donkeys are
incredibly kind animals.
They're a lot nicer than horses.
And they're just --
they're really loving.
-So this is this is --
I think this is gonna --
I think you're really gonna
do this.
-Well, I am definitely
gonna do it.
I don't know if I'm gonna
be successful,
but I'm definitely
gonna do it.
-What inspired you besides --
I mean, do you have your land
or your neighbors, or?
-Well, I've raised cattle
over the course of my life.
I had a few different ranches,
and I did that very seriously
with a great friend of mine
named John English.
And I just --
I really missed the country.
I spent a lot of time,
certainly through "24."
I spent all of that time
in Los Angeles
and through
"Designated Survivor"
and now "Rabbit Hole."
That was all in the city
of Toronto and I missed nature.
-You just mentioned "24",
and I know the fans --
you were nice --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you, thank you.
-We don't have time
for this, Chloe.
I love it.
You've been on the show
so many times for that,
and thank you for coming on,
being a guest.
Fans of "24" are always
wondering on the Internet,
like, "Will you bring it back?
Will there be some type
of '24' spinoff?"
I mean, it's such
a great premise.
-Well, the thing that --
I mean, I've always felt
that the show was
the great star, right?
The idea of a thriller
in real time,
that's just special.
And it should go on forever
with me or without me.
-Well, let me just say
something.
You, my friend,
were the star of that, I mean.
-That's very --
That's very nice.
-There's no one
that could do it like you.
You were unbelievable.
-Thank you.
-But I agree that --
-But if they wrote it,
if -- this is so unfair
to -- Howard Gordon's
gonna kill me for this,
and he was the lead writer
of the last, well,
the last seven seasons of "24."
And but if everybody came up
with a great idea,
I would not be
the person to say,
"no, I would not be the reason
that it didn't come back."
-That's what all I wanted
to hear.
That's all I want to hear.
I loved it.
I used to tune in every week
and I go, "Oh my gosh,"
because you're living --
I'm living your hour with you
until we get to "24."
It was so well done and great.
-Thank you.
-I think I told you last time,
because I ended up
buying the DVD box set,
and I lent it to my friend
at the same time
to watch it, as well.
And he lost one of the DVDs.
So I missed like
three hours of "24."
That's -- You can't do that.
-I'll send them to you.
-You will?
-Yes.
-That's a friend right there.
Thank you, buddy.
I appreciate that.
All right. Put a little pressure
out there just for that "24."
But let's talk about
"Rabbit Hole" here.
I only saw the first episode,
and I'm hooked.
It's fantastic.
It's a thriller.
It's what you want to see
Kiefer Sutherland come in and do
and kick butt and figure out.
There's explosions,
there's action.
I liked -- There's one scene
where you're delivering a box,
you're dressed as the delivery
guy, and you're like,
"I'm delivering this box here."
And the guy's like,
"You got to sign."
You go, "Oh, okay.
I'll just -- can you
hold this box for a second?"
And he goes, "Yeah."
And then you pull
some switch and go,
"You're holding a bomb."
-[ Laughs ]
-It was so good.
-It felt really
familiar, that line.
-It was so good.
-I go, "Oh, I'm hooked, man."
I loved it.
How do we talk about,
how do we describe
what "Rabbit Hole" is about?
-I play a character
named John Weir,
who is involved
in corporate espionage,
which is actually a real thing.
And he's in the middle
of an operation
that goes terribly,
terribly wrong.
And he literally goes
from the hunter
to the hunted
in a matter of moments.
And the rest of the season
is him trying to figure out
who's doing it to him,
why are they doing it to him,
and how does he clear his name
and save his life?
-Yeah, it's fantastic.
You're great in it
as you are.
-Thank you.
-Please come back,
I want to know more
about the farm, too,
when you come back.
-I'll have pictures.
-I want to show a clip.
Here's Kiefer Sutherland
in "Rabbit Hole."
Take a look at this.
-Where are you taking her?
What's your precinct?
What are the charges?
This woman has done nothing,
and they're arresting her.
[ Car horn honks ]
-What are you doing?
-[Bleep] I have it all
on camera.
-Answer him.
-I see you.
We see you, we see you.
-Back off!
-We see you, we see you.
-We see you.
-Hey, we see you.
-We see you, you son of a --
-We can see you.
-We see you!
-Are you ready?
-For what?
-We see you!
-Ready or not.
Gun, gun, gun!
[ People screaming ]
-We see you!
[ Screaming continues ]
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-Yeah, that's what
I'm talking about.
Kiefer Sutherland, everybody.
"Rabbit Hole" premieres
this Sunday on Paramount+.
-Jimin joins us after the break.
Stick around.